ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERONE
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING
IN THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
BARRICADE HIM. BENNETT BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA. BURKE CALDERON. CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU. CHEN CHIU. CHOI
COOLEY. COOPER CUNNINGHAM.
DALLY DAILY. DAVIES FLORA. FONG
USER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KILEY BLACKY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN WHEN
O'DONNELL. LISTEN PETRIE-NORRIS
CORK CORK SILVA RAMOS RADIUS
THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
C. R. TO SMITH. STONE TEAM
MELENDEZ V. PUJA VOEPEL WALDRON
WARD WICKS WORD MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY FAMILY
MEMBER DAILY LIMIT AB. PLEASE
BOW YOUR HEAD DEAR HEAVENLY
FATHER WE COME BEFORE YOU TO
ASK THAT YOU GRANT US WISDOM
EMPATHY AND GRACE WE ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE A HEDGE OF
PROTECTION AROUND THOSE ON THIS
FLOOR AS WELL AS THOSE IN THIS
BUILDING. ONLY YOU KNOW WHAT IS
TRULY GOING ON IN EACH OF OUR
LIVES REMEMBER US REMIND US TO
SHOW MERCY TO ONE ANOTHER IS
YOU HAVE SHOWN MERCY TO US.
LORD I ASK THAT YOU HELP US
REMEMBER TO ALWAYS PUT THE
INTERESTS OF THOSE WE WERE
ELECTED TO SERVE FIRST. IN THE
BOOK IT SAYS TO WHOM MUCH IS
GIVEN MUCH IS EXPECTED WITH
GREAT POWER COMES
RESPONSIBILITY LET US NEVER
LOSE SIGHT OF THE GIFT YOU HAVE
BESTOWED UPON US I THANK YOU
AND PRAISE YOU IN YOUR NAME.
AMEN. THANK YOU MISS DAVIS WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE. PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES. YEAH
OKAY- YEAH COMMITTEE HALF OFF
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED. THE TO
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY SERVICE
WEDNESDAY MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE IS IN THE MEDICINES. AND
MISS WALDRON FOR THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
JUST WITH. PRESENTATIONS AND
PHYSICIANS THERE ARE NONE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ. AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE NONE. LIVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. TODAY'S ABSENCES
WE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MITHRAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR MOTION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE. TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS DAVIES
AND IS THERE ARE YOU TO SPEAK
ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
ABOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER YEAH.
MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING THE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE BILL FIFTY ONE ALL
THOSE WHO DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
LIVING TO THE- THIRD READING
FILE FILE ITEM. TO HR TWENTY
EIGHT THE CLERK WILL READ HOUSE
RESOLUTION TWENTY EIGHT BY SOME
REMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE DAY. MR EVEN IF YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES HOUSE
RESOLUTION TWENTY EIGHT HONORS
AGRICULTURE DAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. IT COMMEMORATES THE
VITAL ROLE OF AGRICULTURE HERE
IN OUR STATE IF YOU'LL IN OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY. FEEDING NOT
JUST CALIFORNIANS BUT PEOPLE
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY AND AROUND
THE WORLD. AS I PREPARE TO
BECOME CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
AGRICULTURE- YEAH COMMITTEE. I
TOOK A TOUR AROUND THE STATE
THIS FALL. I TOOK A TOUR TO
MEET WITH SOME OF THE PEOPLE
GROW OUR FOOD. AND LET ME TELL
YOU THIS THE MAGNITUDE OF OUR
AG INDUSTRY. THE DIVERSE CITY
OF OUR AG INDUSTRY IS TRULY
STAGGERING. WE LEAD THE NATION
IN PRODUCTIVITY OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DIFFERENT
COMMODITIES OVER SEVENTY
THOUSAND FARMS AND RANCHES. AND
pARE INDIVIDUAL AND FAMILY OWNED
FARMS. EVERYWHERE YOU GO IN OUR
STATE PEOPLE ARE GROWING THINGS
THE COMMUNITY GARDENS IN LOS
ANGELES AND SAN JOSE. IN LARGE
FARMS AND RANCHES IN SALINAS
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IMPERIAL
COUNTY TO THE OREGON BORDER. IN
GREENHOUSES IN VENTURA AND
SANTA BARBARA COUNTIES.
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE IS TRULY
EVERYWHERE. AND OVER THE PAST
YEAR AGRICULTURE LIKE MOST
INDUSTRIES ACROSS OUR STATE AND
COUNTRY. HAVE FACED NUMEROUS
CHALLENGES AMONG THIS PANDEMIC
AND THROUGH UR STATE'S
UNPRECEDENTED WILDFIRE SEASON.
YET ACROSS THE STATE FARMERS
CAN'T PLANTING. FARMWORKERS CAP
HARVESTING. SO THAT
CALIFORNIANS SO THAT OUR
COUNTRY COULD KEEP EATING.
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE IS
STRONG IT IS RESILIENT. BUT IS
ALSO FACES SERIOUS AND URGENT
CHALLENGES. WE MUST ENSURE THAT
OUR FARMERS AND RANCHERS HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO RECOVER. FROM
LAST YEAR'S CRISES AND PREPARE
FOR THE NEXT ONES WHICH WILL
SURELY COME. WE NEED REFORMS TO
ENSURE THAT OUR AG INDUSTRY CAN-INNOVATE AND COMPETE IN A
GLOBAL MARKET. WE MUST IMPROVE
OUR ABILITY TO CONSERVE AND
MANAGE WATER SO THAT CROPS
CONTINUE TO GROW AND FLOURISH
IN ARE DROUGHT PRONE STATE. MS
BALANCE ROBUST AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTION WITH STRONG
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS.
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE CAN LEAD
THE WAY. BUT THE BURDEN
SHOULDN'T FALL ON FARMERS ALONE
WE NEED SUPPORT AND RESOURCES
FROM THE GOVERNMENT TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN. FINALLY WE MUST
PROTECT THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS WHO GROW
AND HARVEST OUR FOOD. IF
FARMWORKERS DO NOT HAVE DECENT
HOUSING. IF THEY'RE NOT TREATED
WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT THEN
WE HAVE FAILED. IN THIS STATE
WE LIFT EVERYONE UP AS WE RISE.
AND COLLEAGUES THE THEME OF
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE DAY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO CELEBRATE
THE RESILIENCE. IN RECOGNITION
OF ALL THE PEOPLE WHO KEPT OUR
FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN GOING WHO
ENABLED ALL OF US AND OUR
FAMILIES HAVE FOOD ON OUR
TABLES DURING A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. ENJOY THE WORST
WILDFIRE SEASONS OUR STATE HAS
EVER SEEN. TO ALL CALIFORNIA
FARMERS RANCHERS FARMWORKERS AN
ESSENTIAL FOOD CHAIN WORKERS.
WHO MAKE OUR AG INDUSTRY THE
ENVY OF THE WORLD. WE ARE
PROFOUNDLY GRATEFUL. AND I'D
LIKE TO HAVE THE FIRST ROLL
CALL OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO JOIN ME IN
CELEBRATING CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE'S RESILIENCE AND
STRENGTH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MYSTERY. MEMBERS
AFTER YOU GIVE YOUR RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION OUR COLLEAGUES MISTER
FLOOR YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
INTERPOLATION THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER- MEMBERS I RISE IN
ABSOLUTE SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION AND I WANT TO
APPLAUD THE CHAIR OF AG FOR HIS
COMMITMENT TO HIS CALIFORNIA TO
ARE. YOU TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
ALL OF CALIFORNIA OUR CULTURE
WE ALL COME FROM DIFFERENT
REGIONS A LOT OF CALIFORNIA HAS
AG IN IT BUT WE HAVE DIFFERENT
ISSUES. BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY
ONE THING IS A FAMILY WHO CAME
HERE IN THE TWENTIES FROM NORTH
DAKOTA STARTED FARMING WHO IS
VERY COMMITTED TO CALIFORNIA
HAD. TO EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU THAT DO NOT UNDERSTAND THE
AGRICULTURE WORLD I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU. TO TAKE A TOUR.
TO COME VISIT OUR FARMS. TO
UNDERSTAND THE LEGISLATION THAT
WE PASSED IN THIS HOUSE. HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS. BOTH GOOD AND
BAD TO HAVE AN UNDERSTANDING OF
THE EFFECTS IT HAS ON
CALIFORNIA. AS I WILL
ABSOLUTELY TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
THAT THE FARMERS THE RANCHERS
THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO FOR GROW
YOUR FOOD. ARE SOME OF THE BEST
ENVIRONMENTALISTS YOU'LL EVER
MEET I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER FOR
MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I TOO
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE MY VOICE IN
SUPPORT OF HR TWENTY EIGHT
CLEARING MARCH TWENTY THIRD AND
CALIFORNIA OUR CULTURE DAY.
CALIFORNIA WITH THE U. S. AND
CAST FORMER SEATS. WE GROW OVER
A THIRD OF THE COUNTRY'S
VEGETABLES AND TWO THIRDS OF
THE COUNTRY'S FRUITS AND NUTS.
IN OUR AGRICULTURAL ABUNDANCE
INCLUDES MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED
COMMODITIES. IN ADDITION THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AREA ALONE SHIP
SEVENTEEN BILLION IN
COMMODITIES EACH YEAR. AND OVER
THREE BILLION IN AG COMMODITIES
ARE PRODUCED MY DISTRICT.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FOURTH
LARGEST LEADING WINE PRODUCER
IN THE WORLD BEHIND ITALY
FRANCE AND SPAIN. MITCHELL NOVA
NOT THE SILLY DISTRICT IS IN
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD. WHAT IS
HOME TO OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES OF PREMIUM WINE
GRAPES. AND PRODUCES CLOSE TO
ONE HUNDRED GRAPE VARIETIES.
HELLO LIVES REGION ANNUAL YIELD
OF APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND TONS OF GRAPES IS
VALUED AT OVER THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS. THE COMPRISES
20% OF CALIFORNIA'S WINE GRAPE
PRODUCTION. MORE THE NAPA AND
SONOMA COUNTIES COMBINED. OUR
CULTURE IS CALIFORNIA'S NUMBER
ONE INDUSTRY AND EMPLOYS
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS IN MY
DISTRICT. EVERYTHING WE EAT AND
WHERE AND WHERE IT COMES FROM
AG. AGAIN CALIFORNIA IS IT WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AN ECONOMIC
ENGINE FOR MY DISTRICT THE
STATE IN OUR NATION. NEEDS
SUPPORT OUR HOMEGROWN
AGRICULTURE AND HELP EDUCATE
CONSUMERS ABOUT WHERE THEIR
FOOD COMES FROM. DIPLO
CALIFORNIA GROWN PRODUCE AND
LIVESTOCK. CALIFORNIA AG BRINGS
IN FIFTY BILLION A YEAR AS MORE
THAN ANY OTHER INDUSTRY. LET'S
CELEBRATE CALIFORNIA AG
ANDERSON AYE VOTE ON HR TWENTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER COOPER MISTER VERA COULD
WELL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER. TODAY IS
OUR- I RISE TO SUPPORT HR
TWENTY EIGHT. AGRICULTURE
CONTINUES TO BE AN IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR ECONOMY. AND MY
DISTRICT SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY HAS
OVER THREE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED FORMS. WHICH COVERS
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
TWO THOUSAND ACRES OF LAND. FOR
FARMERS PRODUCE MANY OF THE
PRODUCTS. WE DEPEND ON TO LIVE.
OUR TOP AGRICULTURE FRUIT UP
PRODUCT OF SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY
INCLUDES RICE WALNUTS ALMONDS
CHERRIES PEARS AS WELL AS
LIVESTOCK AND POULTRY PRODUCTS.
AMONG MANY OTHER PRODUCTS SUCH
AS- A NURSERY PRODUCTS AND
WINES. I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SALINAS FOR
BRINGING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION RECOGNIZING THE
CONTRIBUTION OF ALL THE FARMERS
RANCHERS. FARMWORKERS WHO FEED
CALIFORNIA AND THIS WORLD.
THANK YOU MISTER VERA COULD
WALK MISS WALDRON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF HR TWENTY EIGHT.
COMMEMORATING CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE DAY. ALL OF US KNOW
THAT AGRICULTURE IS OF IS VITAL
TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY. WHAT
CAN BE OVERLOOKED IS THAT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRY IS AS
UNIQUE AS AN END OF HORTON AS
THE REST OF THE STATE. SAN
DIEGO COUNTY IS THE NATION'S
NINETEENTH LARGEST FARM ECONOMY
OUT OF OVER THREE THOUSAND
COUNTIES IN THE UNITED STATES
EMPLOYING THOUSANDS AND
FEELINGS MANY ANCILLARY
BUSINESSES. AND THE COUNTY HAS
MORE SMALL FAMILY FARMS UNDER
TEN ACRES THAN ANY OTHER IN THE
NATION. SAN DIEGO COUNTY RANKS
NUMBER ONE NATIONALLY IN PART
TIME FARMERS AND NUMBER TWO IN
FARMS WITH WOMEN AS THE
PRINCIPAL OPERATOR. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS EXTREMELY DIVERSE
IN THE PRODUCTS PRETTIES. WITH
CROPS RANGING FROM NURSERY TO
CITRUS AVOCADOS AND ARE GROWING
WINE INDUSTRY FROM FALL BURKE
TO MACULA IN THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AREA. SAN DIEGO COUNTY
AGRICULTURE RANKS NUMBER ONE IN
HORTICULTURE AND NURSERY CROPS
NUMBER ONE NATIONALLY IN
AVOCADOS PRODUCING 40% OF ALL
THE AVOCADOS GROWN IN
CALIFORNIA. AND NATIONALLY
NUMBER TWO IN ACRES OF GUAVAS
POMEGRANATE GRANITE LINES AND
MACADAMIA NUMBER FIVE IN LEMONS
NUMBER NINE NATIONALLY AND
STRAWBERRIES THE NUMBER TEN IN
EGG LAYING HENS. ED IN SUNSHINE
AND THAT'S WHY I CALL MY
DISTRICT THE HEALTH INDUSTRY I
URGE A NOVEL. THANK YOU MISS
WALDRON MR GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
COLLEAGUES I WORK FOR START.
ACKNOWLEDGING OUR CHAIR FOR THE
APPLE A COMMITTEE BRINGING THIS
RESOLUTION FORWARD. ANOTHER WE-
DO THE IS A- EVERY SINGLE YEAR
I THINK THIS YEAR IS A BIT
DIFFERENT. AND IT'S DIFFERENT
BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE SEEN IS.
THROUGHOUT OUR FARMING
COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE AND IN
THE NATION WE KNOW THAT
FARMWORKERS HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY. EXPOSE AN
IMPACTED BY THIS DEADLY
PANDEMIC THAT'S STILL. BEFORE
US. AND IT'S TAKEN A
PARTNERSHIP MADE GENUINE AND
SINCERE PARTNERSHIP. BETWEEN
OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR FARMERS
TO COME TOGETHER AND PRIORITIZE
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
OUR WORKERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND SO I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FARMERS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHO TRULY. HAVE PUT THEIR BEST
FOOT FORWARD TO PROTECT THEIR
WORKERS. AND ENSURING THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
BRING FORWARD THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES THE VACCINES. TO MAKE
SURE THAT CALIFORNIA
FARMWORKERS AND OUR FARMERS.
CONTINUE TO BE THE NATION AND
OUR STATE. AND SO I JUST WANTED
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS YEAR'S
A BIT DIFFERENT. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT AGRICULTURAL DAY
AGRICULTURAL MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA AND I WANT TO THANK
AGAIN THE CHAIRMAN FOR BRINGING
THIS RESOLUTION FOR. THANK YOU
MR GARCIA MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I MUST
RISE IS VICE CHAIRMAN OF
AGRICULTURE WITH THE CHAIR TO
SUPPORT HR TWENTY EIGHT FOR OUR
AGRICULTURAL DAY- WITH
CALIFORNIA BEING THE MOST
DIVERSE STATE. IN THE UNION
WITH R. FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHT
COMMODITIES GROWING FOOD AND
FIBER- WE DO IT FOUR TIMES
BETTER THAN EVERYBODY ELSE. AND
YOU KNOW I HEARD SOME REALLY
GOOD COMMENTS. FROM OUR
COLLEAGUES AND IN REGARDS TO
ENSURING OUR AG WORKERS ARE
BEING SUPPORTED THAT OUR
FARMERS ARE BEING SUPPORTIVE.
THAT THE IMPACTS OF KOBE. THAT
HAVE DEFINITELY TAKEN A TOLL BE
LOOKED AT. MEMBERS I JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU ALL AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WITH THIS LEGISLATIVE
YEAR AS WE BEGIN OUR- ACTUAL
HEARINGS ON LEGISLATIVE BILLS
THAT WE KEEP IN MIND. THE
OVERALL IMPACTS OF THE ENTIRE
FOOD SUPPLY CLOTHING SUPPLY HOW
THE IMPACT OF THE WORKERS. THE
SMALL FAMILY FARMS. AND ENSURE
THAT WE KEEP CALIFORNIA IS THE
NUMBER ONE AGRICULTURAL STATE
IN THE UNION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER MATHIS STRESS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR THE
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. I TOO WANTED TO RISE
TO LEND SUPPORT TO H. R. TWENTY
EIGHT I SINCERELY APPRECIATE
THE CHAIRS VISIT TO OUR
DISTRICT TO ONE OF THE LARGEST
PRODUCERS OF THE ASIAN FRUITS
AND VEGETABLES HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ALSO
VISITING OUR FOOD BANKS AND THE
FARMER TO FOOD BANK OF PROJECT
THE PROJECT THAT HAS BEEN
UNDERTAKEN- I COME FROM A
COMMUNITY WILL THAT HAS
DIFFERENT KINDS OF AGRICULTURE-
WE HAVE MY AND MY PARTNERS
COMMUNITY AS WELL AS MINE OR MY
COLLEAGUE- THE ORANGES CITRUS
INDUSTRY IS REALLY BIG- BUT-ALSO I WANTED TO RISE AS ONE OF
THOSE YOUNG FARMWORKERS. WHEN I
WAS A PRETEEN PICKING ONIONS
AND GRAPES AND RECOGNIZING THE
HARD WORK THAT IT IS AND GIVING
CREDIT TO ALL OF OUR
FARMWORKERS WHO WORKED SO HARD
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE FOOD IS
HARVESTED AND MADE IT MAKE ITS
WAY TO THE TABLES OF ALL OF
AMERICA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS RARE SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE ON THE MATTER
MYSTERY THIS YOU MAY CLOSE.
AGAIN MADAM WHICH- SPEAKER-
REQUEST WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE AND WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE THE FIRST ROLL CALL OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS THANK YOU THINK
HERE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. COOPER FROM THE
RESOLUTION. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESERVE IT THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT
THIS IS YOUR CO AUTHORS. ALL
MEMBERS. THIRTY TWO ZERO. BURKE
WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY
THAT THERE ARE SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ON SIXTY EIGHT CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION USING A VOICE
NOT ON THE RIVER RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALTHOUGH THE SAY NO YEAH I HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
IN THE DIRECTION WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO THE PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY WE WILL PASS AND RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM THREE. AND THEN
MOVED TO THE PREVIOUSLY NASTY
GERMANS IN MEMORY MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR. HE
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS. WHERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AN INTERMINABLY.
MEMBERS. MISS DAVIS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER YOUR MEMORY THANK YOU
IT IS WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT I
SHARE WITH YOU THAT OUR DEAR
FRIEND COMMUNITY LEADER DOES
NOT BE ANY PASSED AWAY ON MARCH
FOURTEENTH DESTINY'S AN
INCREDIBLE LEGACY IN LAGUNA GAL
TOGETHER WITH HIS WIFE IN HIGH
SCHOOL SWEETHEART DONNA THEY
WORK SIDE BY SIDE FOR MANY
YEARS IN OUR COMMUNITY TO HELP
DEVELOP OUR YOUTH TO BECOME
FUTURE COMMUNITY LEADERS
THROUGH LOCAL BOY AND GIRL
SCOUT TROOPS. MULVANEY'S WERE
ALSO THE ONES THAT BROUGHT THE
CEREMONIAL DELIVERY OF THE FLAG
BY LOCAL BOYS AND GIRL SCOUT
TROOPS TO THE CITY OF LAGUNA
GAL MEETINGS OVER THE HOLIDAYS
DENISON DONNA WOULD COORDINATE
THE DONATION OF THOUSANDS OF
CANS OF NUTS POPCORN AND GIRL
SCOUT COOKIES FOR MILITARY
SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN WILL
PERSONALLY DELIVER THEM TO
LOCAL MILITARY BASES DENNIS WAS
A FOUNDER OF THE LAGUNA GAL
AMERICAN LEGION POST TWO EIGHTY
ONE AND OPPOSED TO EIGHTY ONE
STUDENT SCHOLARSHIP FUND DENNIS
WAS ALSO THE PRESIDENT OF THE
GIVEN THE GAL ROTARY CLUB FROM
200-042-2000 FIVE. IN WITH THE
LOGIN DETAILS TO DISAPPEAR IN
TWO THOUSAND FIVE DANCES
INSTRUMENTAL IN COORDINATING
THE FAMOUSLY GIVEN THE
COOPERATE FOR MANY YEARS AND
WAS A LONGTIME. MEMBER OF THE
MILITARY SUPPORT COMMITTEE. THE
IMPACT MEANT OF ITS KIND.
BELTRE AFTER. WILL BENEFIT OUR
COMMUNITY FOR MANY. THIS LOOK
GOOD ON GAS HAS LOST. TRUE
SERVANT DENNIS WAS DEFINITELY
CAN LEADER. WILL TRULY MISSED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MAY DAVIS.
MISTER NAZARIAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER. MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES TODAY I
RISE IT TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
A DEAR FRIEND STEVE APHRIA-
STEVE WAS A PIVOTAL ADVISOR
INFLUENCER AND FIXTURE IN LA
LOCAL POLITICS FOR FORTY YEARS
HE STARTED HIS CAREER AS A
YOUNG MAN- DECIDED TO JUMP IN
AND RUN FOR OFFICE- AND WHILE
AS TALENTED AND ARTICULATE HE
WAS HE ENDED UP LOSING IT IN A
IN A TIDAL WAVE OF AN ELECTION
IN THE NIGHT IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY. AND THEN HE ATTEMPTED
THAT ONE MORE TIME AND WHEN HE
SAW THAT ELECTED POLITICS
WASN'T WORKING OUT HE PUT HIS
TALENTS TOWARD- MESSAGING AND
COMMUNICATION AND BECAME A
EXTREMELY SUCCESSFUL CONSULTANT
SO MUCH SO THAT A YOUNG
TALENTED CITY COUNCIL MEMBER BY
THE NAME OF ZEV YAROSLAVSKY
AFTER HE WON HIS SURPRISING
ELECTION DECIDED TO HIRE HIM
AND BRING HIM IT IN ON AS HIS
CHIEF OF STAFF. OF AND SO FROM
THERE ON STEVE PUT A LOT OF HIS
TALENT TO WORK- WAS- THE CO
FOUNDER OF THE FIRST EVER- LA
AIDS WALK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
FIVE WENT ON TO HAVE A
SUCCESSFUL CAREER OF FORTY
YEARS DOING HIS CONSULTING WORK
AND IN INTERMITTENTLY WOULD
SERVE AND COUNTY AND CITY AND
STATE BOARDS INCLUDING THE L.
A. COUNTY BOARD OF LICENSE. THE
CIVIL SERVICE COMMISSION LA
CITY ANIMAL SERVICES
REDISTRICTING WEST HOLLYWOOD
INCORPORATION COMMITTEE SO AS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE DENTAL
BOARD- STEVE IS SURVIVED BY HIS
PARTNER AND HUSBAND OF THIRTY
YEARS. CURTIS SANCHEZ. SISTERS
BONNIE AND SORRY. SISTER IN LAW
DEBBIE. AND HIS NIECE AND
NEPHEWS. I JUST WANTED TO
PERSONALLY SAY HOW WONDERFUL OF
A HUMAN BEING STEVE WAS A LOT
OF TIMES. WHEN WE ARE THROWN
INTO THE BATTLE ROUTE LINES OF
THE CAMPAIGN AND WE SEE
DIFFERENT LOBBYISTS COME IN AND
TALK TO US OR POLITICAL
CONSULTANTS- IT'S EASY TO BE
CAUGHT IN THE MOMENT OF THE
CAMPAIGN THAT WERE AND NOT
REALLY THINK OF. THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE HAVING
AT HAND AT THAT MOMENT. STEVE
WAS ONE OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
THAT HE WOULD LEAVE AND
AFTERWARDS YOU WOULD THINK
WELL. THIS PERSON JUST
EXPLAINED TO ME THAT HE'S GOING
TO BE WORKING AGAINST ME IN
THIS CAMPAIGN BUT THIS IS
SOMEONE THAT I'M GOING TO WANT
TO WORK WITH AND TALK TO.
HOPEFULLY WHEN EVERYTHING ELSE
IS DONE BECAUSE- HE JUST HAD
THAT PRESENCE ABOUT HIM. AND
HIS DEMEANOR MANNERISM. ABILITY
TO ARTICULATE AND ABILITY TO
FIND THE COMMON GROUND. TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE ISSUES THAT YOU
FELT WERE VERY IMPORTANT. STEVE
WILL BE SORELY MISSED- BY MANY
OF US WHO KNEW HIM AND- WANTED
TO GIVE MY LOVE AND REGARDS TO
HIS FAMILY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER GRAND MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAME SUGGESTS WE
PRINT IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTED YOUR IN MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ PRINT IN THE
JOURNAL. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
MARCH TWENTY THIRD CHECK IN
SESSION WEDNESDAY MARCH TWENTY
FOURTH CHECK IN SESSION AND
THURSDAY MARCH TWENTY FIFTH
FLOOR SESSION AT NINE AM. ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE PATH
TO RETAIN. ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING HEARING NO
FURTHER THIS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
THIS REYES MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS AT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
MARCH TWENTY FIFTH AT NINE AM.
QUORUM CALL IT LIFTED.